citizens of the reject Nation Ron joxie is back
and we're ready to test our might with Paul
W S Anderson's original Modern Combat did not
leave you hanging Roxy are you excited [Music]
yeah that's right yeah R.I.P my headphones
let's do this thing I know that you were
in the arcades as a kid throwing down mad
coins on this yeah listen I feel like I'm a
big Mortal Kombat fan but also I don't know
if that's true that's good that's perfect
because today we're gonna find out but only
if you leave a like on this video as well as
subscribe hit the notification Bell check out
the world girls and also hey guys I just want
to say a big old thank you to the team over
at prepper for chopping down these highlights
because it's hard work and we appreciate them
for doing it also if you want the entire the
complete Mortal Kombat experience alongside us
see everything that doesn't make these reaction
highlights come on over to patreon.com the
real reject sync up with your own copy and
join us for several other movies and shows as
well it's a real blast Roxy yeah are you ready
that's not a line in the movie I'm not
watching it's okay I got you get over here
yeah [Applause] [Music] oh my God we're just
getting right to it it's like wow all right
okay oh man why wasn't I in a theater
for this I don't know why weren't you
nobody's mad at that never that's like
the most iconic theme song of all time oh
no
let him go man this guy's very different from Ip
Man that kid's a kid right he's a young person
oh so you broke his back okay not cool you
can't be the good guy in the story right no
he's the hero this is the save the cat moment your
brother's soul is mine [Music] oh Liu Kang [Music]
my man
the Western Union brother Dead
return home grandfather Jackson
yeah I'm gonna name you every chance I
get Jax I'm Sonia blade you're because
Sonya Blade I'm so Sonja blade oh
fatality she's here right on time
oh yeah I love punctuality in
a woman I do too Mr Shang sung
not just in a woman and a person though but
yeah only in women dudes can be as late as they
want She'll follow you into hell just make sure
she's on there Sonia blade must be at the turn
Mighty Man Sonia should share a cabin have
our own little Honeymoon Cruise so much
he has values oh no yeah yeah I get that
eye acting in there twitch those lids
the cool guy who is that playing Sonya
Blade I'm not sure where's Kano where is he
asking Australian she looks like Cadet Kelly
oh yeah Miami Vice Johnny caves
that's what I said I don't know I see
palm trees I think L.A or Miami L.A
you're a lot better at this than me I mean I'd
say it's not a competition but it's Mortal Kombat
stands Let's Dance well I wanted
this to be sweet dreams are made
of these so it sounded like we were getting into
what do you think the odds are that we're inside
or is this a real fight I hadn't thought
about it till you said it but why did he
pull up and say let's dance in real life
yeah [Music] this is where you fall down
you knew hey mister you're in my chair oh no hi
Johnny you're one of the best martial artists
in the world and I can help you prove it the
All-Valley tournament the tournament it's held
once a generation the best fighters in the world
are invited Cobra Kai there's a boat leaves Pier
40. Hong Kong tomorrow oh the dragon oh no no you
didn't see that one coming ah he's fighting dirty
it feels like they're using different kinds
of cameras I know it's like they had different
film stocks for every different shoot day or
something but I mean I don't know it does give
it a cinematic quality no it's working it's just
interesting it's like every place is a different
movie this is where we found this spot you follow
it in your footsteps preparing for the tournament
grandfather it wasn't enough you filled my head
with that nonsense how can you a wise man believe
this well you're all blaming it and we all got
money on it he is like maybe the best head of
hair I've ever seen in my entire life I know man
I wish I could get those feathers going also a
lot of smoke shows in this I want to represent the
order of light at the tournament for what reason
the man who killed my brother will be there I
guess that's a good reason we're fighting for
the fate of the world that's why
you left the temple and ran away
isn't it oh who we got the great tournament
was too much responsibility but vengeance
yes that's so much simpler Lord Raiden okay
this isn't your god of thunder and lightning
he's just a beggar he's just a white
guy no a white savior um of course yeah
righteous
Palpatine eyes if you are raided why did you let
Chan die why didn't you protect him why didn't you
I know you are but what am I I'm rubber
you are glue what would be your weapon of
choice ooh I want to learn how to use one of
the like a like a blade on a chain sick I'm
pretty good with the bow style in real life
but I feel like that would be super cool or
nunchucks because they never get respect
on screen except for in like John Wick 4
and Bruce Lee movies you want me to carry your
luggage I pay money you carry the bags I got it
yeah buddy
oh both of them didn't look
good in that exchange it's okay
oh my God what is that I feel
like we're at Disneyland right now
or whatever the show they do Hold On Come to
Papa he looks like a Hemsworth that's right kaino
Hemsworth the Lost Hemsworth that's good thanks
it's a dead-on Kano Hemsworth impression hey Sonia
I wonder if they choose chose to do so much ADR
because of the tradition of like Martial Arts
Cinema or maybe it's just a thing that happened
or they had a bad bad audio day every day
it's an honor to finally meet you Sonia At Your
Service oh I'm looking for a murderer but it
is my boat and if you'd like a tour I'd love
to give it to you myself it'll be 28 dollars
just doing her job when I want backup
a radio fort it really enunciates every word
yeah when I want to back up I'll radio for it
and Scorpion damn move aside oh look at that
and that's how he got his name [Music] okay
looks more like Toucan Sam follow your nose
that was a weird series of
shots we'll let them have it
enough damn that is expressly forbidden
before the tournament won't happen again
I promise you until we reach the island
Where You Have No Dominion my dominions
are well known to me sorcerer stop talking
about my Dominion you've been chosen Sonia
Chosen One what you're about to face is vastly
more important than your ego oh your enemy
or your quest for Revenge the focus he was
talking to each of them individually defend
the realm of Earth in a tournament called Mortal
Kombat The Forsaken land called out world ruled by
any mortal now he seeks a new world to conquer an
enslave yes went to the realm of Earth the empress
demon sorcerer Shang Tsung and his Warriors have
to win 10 straight victories in Mortal Kombat the
f19 oh no this will be the 10th Sonia a handful
of people on a leaky boat Are Gonna Save the World
like those odds what about the others they're
all great Fighters but I have looked into
their souls oh and yours one of you three will
decide the outcome of the tournament spoilers
rebellions will depend upon you
because comedy I guess so if you
challenge chang song now you will
lose your life and your soul he is
going to pay for my brother's death
oh look it has begun look the eagles
fly on the Wind to Mordor Wowie
there's Harry
[Applause]
okay you've done a good job identifying
every character though for people who
don't know Mortal Kombat at all you
get a good sense so far it's like if
you used to play as a refresher if you've
never played before you know definitely
who's the game character yeah wow man
this face planted right in the water
let's go [__]
not Johnny is they cast him to be just like an LA
actor guy but like I'm like I really believe this
guy's a like a warrior yeah I know I know like I'm
sure he'll get his chance to shine but I always
think you can walk to the top of the steps I'm
like I feel like you really prioritize the actor
part more than like the actual martial artist
part well I've never seen him work since this
ah of course she's our most dangerous
adversary one so carefully reptile
keep her away from these humans
oh
no dude
oh I felt that these agents were not happy that
their actors were not able to have their faces
you know I know plenty the sounds are so great too
oh no oh no oh yeah poor guy okay Flawless victory
yes words I have seldom heard in this life
knows where knows what she's wondering right
man when she sets her mind on something it's
not her mind you're admiring good point
so Johnny's here for his career yeah if
he wins the tournament people will take him
seriously as a martial artist like his is the oh
zagoro I want to get to the bottom
of this are you out of your mind fast
the minds of Moria TDK Trilogy starts now
that's Kano volcano where was the other guy
yeah is it any freezer this guy right really
have a turkey leg right now disgusting what I
want to know if this Shang sunglies so great
how come he's got such a crummy looking boat
slaves souls he learned the Black Arts from the
emperor himself oh my where's the emperor you're
some kind of royalty too right I am general of
the armies of outwork and Prince of subterranean
potato something like underground yeah exactly
I've come to warn you that gong Laos descending
is competing in the tournament I saw this new Kang
in the hall heel pose no problem he looked like an
idiot princess Katana is 10 000 years old and the
rightful heir to the throne of outworld but she
must not be allowed to join with the forces
from the realm of Earth especially you can
they're very good hiders yeah and these
guys are great at giving out exposition
it's very dank down here is it drippy moist it
is drippy moist there's like a
leaky tap in the background oh
gex invisible kicks
oh pepper spray yeah you got Jurassic parked
[Music]
it's a long time since we've
had a fight come on let's go
it's like burned into my subconscious [Music]
more DJs to play this at clubs and
then maybe I'd go I know right you
just need to be clubbing with like
8th graders it's like the best song
did they put a bowling pin sound in there
nicely done it's a good pose
too absolutely brilliant
an accent so why don't you show me what you
plan to do about them it's an Ever evolving
accent all right the accent itself has
a character Arc uh no I don't think so
what is the little chuckle just gonna
punctuate everything I say now with
tomorrow the Tournament begins be
prepared there are some cool sets
and like [Music] yeah I agree it's like
it makes it so much more jarring when
the other ones are kind it's kind of all
working for me though it's like [Applause]
this is a very exciting moment for me I bet look
at these two I'm super in psyching each other out
it's not mental combat though mental combat
do you remember a lot of these
locations in the game I probably
don't have like that good of a yeah like
oh I'm gonna recognize every level like
yeah I'm sure this is similar to a
level and I've probably seen it but
[Applause]
bad oh so cool if you can do that you can
really do anything your soul is mine yep
it's not a nice thing to do to somebody I
mean that very true Shang Tsung is not a nice
mentality fatality [Music] oh no who do we got it
seems like there's like so many parodies I know
it's perfect chest hair a perfect
smile on your partner though
oh no yeah what is Jack's not
coming back yeah study this
what song is this this isn't the Mortal Kombat
song this is an interesting preparing we had a
knife okay you know I mean half of them have magic
I don't think there are any sort of weapon rules
at all no no just she she only has her decent
fight I think they don't care oh spit on oh
yes choke them out oh give me a break okay
oh
damn what what where was he just go where is this
this is happening or is this sanction in combat
get over here yes parts of that
visual effect look alright but
oh shaving away at that tree bark just what
is this part of the Mortal Kombat I mean I
think they're just throwing in fights World
Combat but that's like I can't tell if this
is part of it this is a really cool setting
now I think they're walking around and they
found this location they're like this tree bleeds
[Music] I was gonna say this seems like an attempt
oh damn maybe it's like Shang Tsung trying to
take them out so that they don't get to fight
[Music]
all right
yeah
[Music] [Applause]
okay but your career does
need you to keep your face
no money maker comes back with a cool
scar though so the winner of this fight
then what I'm not sure I still feel
like this is just an attempt to like
take Johnny off the board without him
actually being in Mortal Kombat but
really make sure we can see those milky eyes oh
sweet this is so just so evil dead right now
that's on my list of things I haven't seen what
whoa [Music]
[Music]
wow I mean I'm conflicted because I guess they
just killed scorpion Bros that was kind of cool
it's kind of badass yeah yeah I'm curious how
that plays the rest of the movie it's a cool fight
oh [Music]
if you won't fight with all of your heart there
is no hope why do you care if I win or lose I
know a shadow there to win your next match
use the element which brings Life water
that's enough you disappoint me not very wise
so for the next fight like that was that clear as
to like what the formal because like structures
that's what three official fights and then
one side quest was that on an official fight
I guess I mean Shang Tsung was there so I just
I'm just gonna assume that his officials somehow
right to business so is
this one sanctioned [Music]
oh no the element that's just she said it
what oh in case we didn't get it at
that point nah man this guy's a master
what on Earth
it's okay buddy you got this get
yes Ryan all right he is you know they're working
with the limitations of this massive puppet
yeah [Music] it's only so out you
can get yeah get out [Applause]
right that's what I like to hear
quite a climactic finishing move
bunk the Royal bunk [Music] raising him up
is an offering noise mine oh why didn't he
take the princess's soul I don't know I mean she's
still on the table right but that was a fight whoa
despair is the most dangerous fear of all I
know this and so does shanksong he can appear
into your soul he he can be into your soul come
on it sounded like I just want to know what that
would feel like somebody pee into my soul please
internet do not do your thing I guess does that
goes sterile I miss it better than someone [__]
in your soul I feel like I've had people [__] on
my soul you go up against him he'll kill you
if I don't then he'll finish us off one at a
time you're making this all sound really simple
and it isn't yeah it is because I can't let what
happened to Art happen to you oh oh he likes her
Yep they're the two attractive white protagonists
it was predestined challenging Gore away I'm not
the one who's gonna die in return I reserve the
right to challenge the winner myself in a place
designated by me they're bad terms and conditions
he brought it back oh what he
just punched him in the nuts
sorry this movie has to know it's it's
funny it's a comedy right it has to know
yes get it in the super wide
oh this is where you fall down you know what
happens with toad when it gets
struck by lightning [Applause]
oh princess or no wait that's Sonya Blade
all right either way no Sony no it's the
love of his life Sonia of course they're
romance I challenge you were a coward
sorcerer extend and fight we had a deal
remember I'm simply changing the place
okay is there an audience
this time or no audience wow
no you can't watch it's one of those no watch
places she has to accept the challenge oh there
can be no final combat I have nothing further
to teach you looking you have learned all the
rules all the disliking now is the will
you sure you don't want to go with us in
our world if you look hard enough you will
find another guy still gotta fight lizard
Luke Cage they are Luke Cage oh
my God what a Duo power man who
needs Luke Cage when you have Luke
Cage Heroes for hire right here
we should head for that Tower Shang Tsung would
have taken Sonia there wow so she doesn't have
to accept the fight but she doesn't know she
doesn't have to accept the fight so they gotta
get there to tell her that I guess so for a
very climactic end what are you doing boom
what size is he supposed to be
I guess these things are alive did it just feed it
now it comes back to life or oh [__] resurrected
uh that's not what he meant to do right is it one
of them or is it like a third one I don't know
[Music]
[Music] [Applause] where is Johnny
is this outside waiting around
yes
get him [Music]
like this seems like a a little bit unnecessary
considering he's already dead and then you
strangled the gotta get more pair UPS going
two steps forward five steps back [Music]
okay it's worth it for that we're not seeing his
feet move but we did hear it and it sounded bomb
oh my bugs nutritious slimy and satisfying [Music]
squash that mean old lizard Hakuna Matata what a
wonderful phrase my father was a rightful ruler
of that world and the emperor entered the realm
killed my parents and adopted me to lay claim
to the throne it's our responsibility in the
Black Tower you will face three challenges you
must face your enemy you must face yourself
and you must face your worst fear and then you
will answer these riddles three what on Earth they
took the time to tease her hair Slave Leia that's
what's happening you don't fight the realm of
Earth will forfeit the tournament and its portals
will open to our great my friends will come
they're already here oh we already came that was
unbelievable yeah that's the best moment of the
whole movie yeah I am Liu Kang descendant of Kung
Lao I challenge you to Mortal Kombat do you accept
[Music] nice dress
bizarre such weird Chemistry Between all
these people yes let's do this one more time
[Music]
that is pretty cool shot
from above come on [Music]
yes Gaines no no you make me
bleed my own blood nobody makes
me sound source of all Shang Tsung's power The
Souls of a thousand dead Warriors a didgeridoo
hey uh that was a pretty cool effect
is your enemy five henchmen
it feels like unfair what are the rules like
are there any rules These Are the souls I know
the rules are probably not the the first order
of business but like are there any parameters
to any of these battles no no it's more clear
of the game can you wipe your chin bro [Music]
but half these guys are like
recognizable stunt actors damn
that dude I can see into your soul
okay you will pee until you die
see your Schwartz is as big as mine face yourself
you can look into my soul but you don't own it
you haven't peed on it yet that is how you take
ownership like a dog face me oh I knew it hello
you fall for it you just saw him do it chin
[Music] right he didn't send me to help
you you're not really cheap remember when
our parents died and you promised that you
would always take care of me uh-huh now it's
my turn to take care of you brother by killing
you in Mortal Kombat come with me want to die
forgive you for letting me die why is he
entertaining no idea it wasn't my fault
Chan chose his own path every man is responsible
for his own destiny Samsung killed my brother
oh my [Laughter] careful you got
all the spikes down there now
it looks like little Christmas
trees yeah or a bunch of little
scorpions under there just pushing
their Palm knives up to the floor
the two of them seem to be the two best
fighters so I like watching them fight
they are easily my two favorite characters I think
let him go Freddy Krueger where do they go
when they escape him get out into the ozone
is that what Global boiling is yeah it's just
all the soul energy let out of Shanks songs
save your save you dizzy for the
week he does not know how to spit
don't pity him [Music]
so close boy you're so close
take a hike to this bike
[Music] there you go a little
lightning out there damn
whoa
is that everybody's soul is
getting released I guess so
now it's the haunted mansion out to poster guys
I said Poltergeist it's all good oh ghost stuff
I knew you'd come okay oh buddies one day sweet
we will be reunited but until then my spirit
will always be with you oh very sweet moment
so long Thackery Binks [Applause]
ah it's like a Shakespearean romance
humans are so unpredictable this is
the end of being girls I've got to tell you
something you guys did great this is so weird
what is it the emperor oh no oh whoa
I don't think so
let's go let's go Paul Anderson
I gotta see that girl's name oh boy
oh boy that was a lot that was a lot
how do you feel it's immediate first thoughts
podcast listen once I decided it was a comedy
I had a blast sure but like I If I had seen this
in theaters when it came out and hadn't talked to
anybody I think I would have been like a rather
confused yes I think five so well also that what
are your immediate thoughts yeah I mean I can
absolutely see why and how this is garnered a
cult following yeah total it's Cult Love so that
that is how it is Christopher Lambert that was
Raiden's name I I always I always hear about
his performance in this movie you know like
Christopher Lambert in Mortal Kombat is always
like one of those meme performances that gets
brought up oh interesting that was him uh uh yeah
I'd be like this is I don't have like the greatest
lexicon like I haven't played every single Mortal
Kombat game and that was you know like those kinds
of games especially when I was young and growing
up were the kinds of things I would have to get at
like a friend's house or in an arcade oh cool the
the uh ADI guys did uh Goro as well they are uh
uh effects folks oh here we go here we go I
already saw Sonya Blake Bridgette Wilson which I
I I must have seen her in something because that
name doesn't even ring a bell but definitely I
feel like I've seen her I've seen a few of these
people I want to look up what else they've done
yeah since then but yeah like I don't have the
best you know overall lexicon to sit here and be
like well in the game lore and stuff like that but
um but yeah like this was very fun but disjointed
and yeah disjointed is a good word for it because
definitely yeah and given the meme status that
this movie possesses in popular culture it is
kind of a funny one to go back and look at it
and two uh you know at the time of filming this um
I think this will go up before it but we did a we
did a different reaction to the Street Fighter
movie and that one has like sort of a more mad
cap tone throughout whereas this like really kind
of dips in and out of like okay here's just kind
of like a still quiet scene of people talking
about stuff and then like randomly a fight will
break out and then that fight will just randomly
transition with no transition into a different
like Paul WS Anderson has made so many movies and
granted this is early on in his career but like
this does feel like like it was assembled by like
a really enterprising film student or something
like that yeah definitely act like a through
line that was cohesive and everything was um
contributing to it you know which is totally fine
because it was fun but yeah some of the rules like
that you and I kept talking it's like wait what I
left this with very little concept of the actual
like world and rules of Mortal Kombat outworld
this whole Mystic you know it's like a whole
mystical ritual that they've got going on yeah
if they win 10 times they can come destroy the
Earth and yet the the fighting which is so much of
the movie so much of the time did just feel like
of just a bunch of fight scenes this really did
feel like they had a bunch of fight scenes and
they're like I don't know we gotta put these
in an order now uh let's get a bunch of scene
scenes and let's just kind of put them here and
there throughout but not between every fight and
to have that it's such a weird structure you're
gonna be so annoyed with me at home and I get it
but like as lover of Love shipper of ships then to
like not have all of a sudden you guys are in love
see that's the thing is as often as I am like
give me a cool love story you know like this kind
of earn it you can't just like say it and then
also there was no Makey Audi at the end there's
two couples and I'm like wait what well that's
the thing is is this this is a movie I certainly
would not come into expecting any kind of romance
and I'm fine with that like especially in a Mortal
Kombat scenario I'm like I don't need it here if
they want to do it I'm always welcoming but in
this case it is it it feels so much like a like
a like a pitch meeting episode where it's just
like they're in love now why because they're both
attractive and they're two of the main characters
like it's what about the other two as well Lou
and the princess uh Katana and Luke Kang like
yeah like at the end they were walking together
they seem chummy you guys have more of like uh you
know Destiny slash you know uh Heritage kind of
thing going on so you guys are together and uh you
guys are are white you guys are Browner and you
guys are whiter so we gotta push together feels
like it feels like somebody decided in editing
that that was supposed to happen and then they
just kind of maneuvered the footage yeah and like
I if anybody's gonna like be couples it's gonna
be me but I was just like what yeah like I don't
know I'd rather it if earlier on just like I'd
rather uh Johnny grabbed her and kissed her and
her been like it what no or something just some
kind of like yeah anything I don't know anything
to establish or to build that up it does feel just
like a regular old Hollywood thing to do and two
because like Shang Tsung and Kano like everybody's
also being like creepy and oogling Sonia as well
so then you're like well why is that starting a
princess is super hot too and then like at the end
with the like I knew it was all gonna happen just
like I'm telling you that was the Mean Girls yeah
and Raiden like is such a again like I'm not like
the gatekeeper of of you know authenticity to the
Mortal Kombat lore but I'm like I don't know what
the choice was for this because he's got I I love
movies like this too that have so much ADR because
inevitably you'll have like these kind of types
of performances arise uh and one of the bingo card
for me is uh when you have like a voiceover that
like doesn't seem at all like the actors watching
the performance while they're giving the voice
over yeah and like all of Raiden's lines felt
kind of like that to me it felt like it was like
an extra microphone on him that was weird it was
like because he's always talking kind of down
here and then like no matter what energy level
the scene calls for he's always tucking like this
strange accident hey [Music] it's just yeah it
has again it has that sort of little kiddish
storytelling quality where it's just like and
then we go here and then this happens and then we
go here he looks like Carrie always a little bit
yeah do you think let me ask you a question
that you're not gonna like but I'm asking anyway
do you think it's possible that this was a bad
movie uh I think it's possible see funny enough
this one I enjoyed yeah I enjoyed it too I'm I
I'm not saying did you or did you not enjoy it
is it possible this is just not a good movie I
enjoyed this I think this certainly is or I see
why this has it's called status yeah uh it this
is not a very good movie okay in a way that like
I'm actually a little bit surprised by uh and
and maybe it's just because like yeah what like
watching Street Fighter and I'm not gonna spend
much time comparing them but Street Fighter is
a similarly kind of wacky Bonkers adaptation of
a fighting video game same concept just slightly
different Aesthetics but that movie maintains like
a cranked up to 10 energy all the way throughout
so like the fun spirit is always there and you're
like even if this wasn't intended to be fun I
think like everyone was having fun whereas this I
can't tell what the motivations were half the time
and it really feels like it's weird because Paul W
S Anderson has made so many video game movies and
he seems to care and yet every single time I see I
haven't even seen that many but like whenever I've
seen him attempt it it's always like did you did
you actually play that like did you did you just
like see someone playing this and go oh I can make
a script off of that and then just take what you
remembered and come up with this movie yeah like
because yeah like it's got the characters that you
might recognize certainly at least a couple so we
we did set up we were like okay so Sonia Blade's
partner was killed by Kano yeah so that's why
she's here yeah and then Lou's brother was killed
so that's why he's here yeah and then Johnny wants
to be a bigger action star so that's why he he
wants to be taken seriously seriously okay so we
at least like the and then they were all super
different from each other so that worked still a
little confused on the princess like why why she
hasn't been killed like she seems to Super not
be with the the she seems to be with our people
right like yeah but she doesn't seem to have as
like as much power to move around and use her
you know ancient so that was interesting and then
um why is what uh white-haired dude's name again
Raven Raiden Raiden Raven Raiden might as well
be what is Raiden's motivation uh you know he's
the protector of Earth Realms so he just wants to
help us win so that he can keep protecting right
okay okay yeah yeah I mean there I think that
this had the ability to have a stronger story
that's cool Flawless victory was fun at least it
was fun I think it could have had a stronger story
it was definitely fun it was fun I think there are
moments where it gets a little bit stiff and there
are moments where and and two like there is a lot
of action and I and I don't think the action is
I mean you know obviously there are better
examples of quality action in cinema
um but for what this kind of movie is you expect
a certain amount of action that's what you want
that's what you're here for they delivered that
and I think a lot of the fights are pretty cool
pretty neat I do feel like this is another movie
where I'm like I wish they put maybe just a little
bit more care into accentuating the choreography
and like you could tell what's going on you could
see the fights there's some decent action in
here I think and it's fun to see the characters
Collide and see uh sets that resemble sets from
the game um but at the same time I'm like man do
some more long takes and let us really drink in
the choreography in the back and forth and stuff
like that that's another thing this movie doesn't
really have they don't really have any fatalities
whatsoever which is like a big part of the games
like those you know those moments where it's like
here's a really gruesome finishing move yeah
they just kind of say it but there's no actual
finishing moves that's interesting yeah this
is just an odd thing so it's like and a lot of
the deaths and things there are moments there
are a couple yeah but just not that variety is
the spice of life yeah and I mean you know that's
that's one thing the more recent remake did hone
in on is okay at least when they're doing some
kind of finish him moment they're do have like
a big puncture would have kind of very striking
move that they do but anyway for what this was in
in the 90s do are you surprised to not have had
any like a-listers we're looking right now on
this Wiki and it says Cameron Diaz was initially
cast as Sonya Blade it kind of feels more around
the lines that you would think that there would be
in the 90s at this time for Mortal Kombat movie I
mean yeah and again it's funny because I think you
know it's like a you look at a movie like Street
Fighter and that has like Jean-Claude Van Damme
Jean-Claude Van Damme and like a bunch of other
recognizable people whereas here you pretty much I
mean you have uh Christopher Lambert and you have
uh you know Carrie hiroyuki tagawa as uh tagawa
as um Chang Tsung like they're to me the most
recognizable Bridget Wilson but yeah it doesn't
seem like they had the full range of both like
recognizable actors but also like recognizable
martial artists and stuff like that too you have
to click on Bridget Wilson it's driving me
insane she must be the star of a TV show or
something else that I've seen she apparently did
her own stunts for this okay well she's in the
Last Action Hero and Billy Madison and uh some
other things okay so I've seen her in a bunch
of stuff yeah I know what you've been on Last
Summer but yeah like okay Frasier it certainly
has like I liked a lot of the sets and stuff like
that and a lot of like the crazy you know temples
and skeletons and monster creatures and stuff like
that uh there's a lot of really do you like Goro
he's he's neat he's neat for what the movie is uh
I think you know again doing the whole like punch
him in the nuts thing is like very that was
hysterical silly 90s thing to do I was stoked
with that moment because that made me think that
the movie knows that it's funny like it was like
yeah we're gonna have him punch him in the nuts
it's certainly yeah gave it a sense of of innate
cheekiness which I appreciate yeah uh I guess
yeah and they're like I thought the effect and
the choice to make that a practical puppet and
animatronic and performer hybrid effect was a
cool idea and I certainly really enjoyed watching
it there are a lot of I mean I gotta hand it to
uh you're saying the whole thing was a puppet yeah
I mean I'm sure it seems like there's somebody in
there yeah I mean I thought you maybe have one
set of arms that's that's you know right maybe
there's a person in the puppet suit that's what
it looks like and then they're probably wearing
a helmet that someone's radio controlling because
you know I mean uh I got to go to ADI uh the Alec
Gillis and and uh and Woodruff and Gillis the two
guys uh credited there they have you know like an
effects house and stuff like that and they've
done like a lot of really cool animatronics
and puppeteering and things like that and various
other movies like The Predator stuff and but yeah
like that I thought was a cool effect I'm aware
it's an effect uh I think it might have played
better if there wasn't so much questionable CG
around as well because you know it's funny because
you'll watch stuff from this era that has certain
elements of CG and lately I've been seeing things
where I'm like oh looks surprisingly good for
the time at least um and in this you know like
most of the CG looks like you're watching it on
like a PlayStation one you know like it it kind
of looks okay when uh the little night you know
the the mouthy knife bits come out of Scorpion's
hands but even that's kind of wonky looking the
lizard effect is certainly like your it you know
reminded me of gex or something like that some
kind of old video game would you watch this again
uh with people probably I don't think I would have
as much fun just watching it alone and putting it
on but you know it's got that cozy 90s aesthetic
it's got some again Vibes these like archaic
ancient temples and stuff like that like I like
The Vibes of this I think it's fun but uh you know
as a Mortal Kombat movie it could be giving you
more stuff I guess um you know it was fun it was
decent I didn't I didn't quite immediately just
like love this the way I think you might if you
were there at the time but I certainly appreciated
the experience I certainly uh had fun getting
acquainted with the memes that this movie has
birthed and has you know become in and of itself
um there are characters I would have like you know
it would have been cool to see Molina who's got
like the big uh crazy like um demon mouth that
opens up and you know she's a kind of violent
and cool character and uh and you know I don't
know if they were if she was even invented at
the time for Mortal Kombat 3 I think is the movie
they were trying to Hawk for this but uh either
way I mean yeah you got your requisites like you
got your Sub-Zero and your Scorpion and angoro
obviously uh uh and then yeah Johnny Cage Let's
see we got the whole list Liu Kang Sean Connery
was offered the role of uh Raiden which also
would have been like a funny like Highlander
thing that would have been cool um yeah Liu
Kang Johnny Cage Shang Tsung Sonya Blade Katana
Kano Scorpion Sub-Zero reptile uh and we had Jax
although he just dies off screen which is a bummer
um I thought it was interesting how much that
director did look like Steven Spielberg the
one that was doing cage yeah he scrolled while I
was reading sorry about that yeah you're trying
to make me look stupid like you better remember
Sandy Helberg as the Director of cage is saying
and initially they're saying it was supposed to
be Steven Spielberg which have been so cool but
he looked so much like Spielberg on the thing you
know what I'm talking about yeah no no it's always
like oh damn that must be a reference yeah and
then it was supposed to be him that's interesting
God this is an interesting movie okay
on Rotten Tomatoes there's a 45 yeah
I mean you know yeah I think that's that kind
of sums it up they say despite an effectively
otherworldly atmosphere inappropriately cheesy
visuals Mortal Kombat suffers from its poorly
constructed plot laughable dialogue and subpar
acting and it is one of those movies where
it's not going so hard and just so mad cap that
that it just like gives way to just a barrage
of fun like you know there are there are some flat
moments in here where you're like oh yeah I'm kind
of watching a a not great movie that is very fun
to behold yeah you know I would assume audiences
would have liked this more than critics which it
seems like they did yeah sure and again like I get
what's lovable about this um it's just yeah it's
just not as like cranked up to 11 in terms of like
memeable uh it's not like silly at all times you
know you know but there are there are a couple I
haven't seen all these memes that you're talking
about I gotta go look I just like this movie just
has that status you know it's like it's looked at
as one of like you know people still hold this up
as one of the better video game adaptations and
for its time certainly I think it is taking the
subject matter with some seriousness subject
matter with some seriousness it's at least
attempting to translate what the thing is even if
it's doing it in a very sort of add yeah kind of
Half Baked sort of away like it feels very
kind of off the cuff a lot of this stuff
um it feels like they showed up a lot of the time
just to the set and we're just like I don't know I
guess we'll just shoot over here and now we've got
a lot of trees in the forest it feels like they
made up on the set they were like we got a boat
set today I guess we're doing this what are we
having at our disposal yeah totally uh well yeah
yeah it's still it's still a very very enjoyable
time uh I think I like Street Fighter a little
better than this but I I still enjoyed this quite
a bit you've got a journey ahead of you and then
you can come back and tell me which one you liked
better okay um but okay I will any final thoughts
before we hit the road you know what no no nothing
else to say about good old Mortal Kombat you're
not excited for Mortal Kombat Annihilation 1997.
that's the thing yes same actor sequel I imagine
I don't know but actually you never know honestly
the way these movies work yeah I would watch
it I would happily I would happily watch it I
do feel that because I didn't I was not miserable
sitting here I was excited sitting here yeah it's
just like huh yeah yeah yeah it does it's a very
hot kind of thing and there's a lot of like random
plot threads that you're like wait hold on what
yeah just I just I could have used yeah just like
a little more structure to what it even means
to be at Mortal Kombat because once they show
up it's just kind of a hodgepodge of like I guess
there's fighting kind of everywhere and like how
is this different than Earth and it's like um
there's like a bunch of people who showed up to
compete here we never see again you know like it's
so it's such a strange movie but hey it was a good
song he took their souls and he eventually gave
them back though we won Earth is safe we didn't
give them back makes you happy this is a true
story this is the story of how we were saved
um interesting well guys why don't you
save us in the comments by leaving your
favorites uh part about this movie favorite
characters something you wanted more of leave
us your thoughts whatever they might be and hey
before we get out of here let's do a patreon
Brian Perry I can just imagine hearing that name
on the start screen of a Mortal Kombat type game
Brian and then I was gonna make you do it right
on battery Brian Brian Perry that's good that's
good Brian Perry wins we said on um the other
video on the Street Fighter video we picked a
patron who's gonna have to go up in a street
fight but now Mortal Kombat against another
Patron so Brian Perry you are going to have to
unlock your supernatural abilities as well as
your destiny figure out what your finishing moves
are what style of fighter you might be we'll even
have some advice like what would yours look like
you know we gotta give them some things to choose
from what should Brian Perry be okay Brian Perry
um oh it's like a sideways what was that what do
you what were you imagining well imagine fists or
is that like a weapon of some kind no those are my
Chop Chop what are what do you what is the job
try to give Brian a weapon and I don't know I
better give him a finishing move okay so you're
gonna do the chop chop yeah yeah cause then they
and then their body Slinky there you go and then
their body like yes apart and uh and bleeds you
know in all different directions yeah if you can
hunch somebody in the dick as a move then you can
do the job job that'll be it that'll be the one
to punch you you can chop chop and then finish
with with the nut punch finish him and that's how
you will take down pandemic Jones when we finally
make you fight to the death in Mortal Kombat but
for right now stay pledged that's the easiest way
to keep Earth realm safe and uh hey we'll catch
you on the next one love you buddy peace out